Hace unos 10 años, emprendí la tarea de enseñar desarrollo global
a estudiantes universitarios suecos. Fue después de haber pasado
unos 20 años estudiando las hambrunas en África con instituciones africanas,
por lo que se esperaba que yo supiera algo sobre el mundo.
En nuestra Universidad de Medicina, el Instituto Karolinska,
di origen a un curso universitario llamado Salud Global. Pero cuando uno tiene
una oportunidad así, se pone un poco nervioso. Pensé: estos estudiantes
que vienen a aprender con nosotros tienen el nivel más alto que se puede
obtener en los sistemas universitarios suecos... pueden saber todo
lo que enseñaré. Por eso preparé una evaluación previa para cuando llegaran
Una de las preguntas de la cual aprendí mucho fue esta:
"¿Qué país tiene el mayor índice de mortalidad infantil de estos cinco pares?"
Agrupé los países de manera tal de que en cada par
uno de los países tuviera el doble de mortalidad infantil que el otro. Y esto implica que
la diferencia es mucho mayor que la incertidumbre de los datos.
No los evaluaré ahora, pero la respuesta es Turquía,
con el índice más alto, Polonia, Rusia, Paquistán y Sudáfrica.
Y estos fueron los resultados de los estudiantes suecos. Lo hice para obtener
el intervalo de confianza, que resultó bastante limitado, y me sentí feliz,
sin duda: un 1,8 de respuestas correctas en 5 posibles. Esto significa que
había lugar para un profesor de salud internacional...
(Risas) y para mi curso.
Pero una noche, mientras recopilaba datos para un informe
realmente tomé conciencia de mi descubrimiento. He demostrado
que, estadísticamente, los estudiantes suecos de primer nivel tienen un conocimiento
del mundo significativamente más bajo que los chimpancés.
(Risas).
Porque un chimpancé lograría la mitad del puntaje correcto si le diera
dos bananas con Sri Lanka y Turquía. Estarían en lo correcto la mitad de las veces.
Pero los estudiantes no logran ese resultado. Para mí el problema no fue la ignorancia:
sino las ideas preconcebidas.
También realicé un estudio no muy ético de los profesores del Instituto Karolinska
(Risas).
...el mismo que entrega el Premio Nobel de Medicina...
y están al mismo nivel que los chimpancés en este tema.
(Risas).
Fue ahí cuando me di cuenta de que existía una necesidad real de comunicar
porque los datos de lo que está sucediendo en el mundo
y la salud infantil en cada país se conocen bien.
Diseñamos este software que se visualiza así: cada burbuja es un país.
Este país que ven aquí es China. Este es India.
El tamaño de la burbuja representa la población, y en este eje pongo la tasa de fertilidad.
Porque lo que respondían mis estudiantes
cuando analizaban el mundo, y les pregunté:
"¿Qué piensan realmente del mundo?"
Bueno, lo primero que descubrí es que su principal libro de referencia era Tintin.
(Risas)
Y respondieron que el mundo sigue siendo `nosotros´ y `ellos´.
Y nosotros significa el Mundo Occidental y ellos el Tercer Mundo"
Les pregunté qué era para ellos el mundo occidental
"Bueno, larga vida y familia pequeña, y el Tercer Mundo es corta vida y familia numerosa"
Eso es lo que puedo mostrar aquí. Pongo la tasa de fertilidad aquí: la cantidad de hijos por mujer,
uno, dos, tres, cuatro, hasta ocho por mujer.
Tenemos buenos datos desde 1960-1962 sobre el tamaño familiar en todos los países.
El margen de error es pequeño. Aquí pongo la expectativa de vida al nacer,
que va de 30 años en algunos países a más de 70.
Y en 1962, realmente había una cantidad de países aquí.
Países industrializados que tenían familias pequeñas y largas vidas.
Y estos eran los países en desarrollo:
tenían familias numerosas y vidas relativamente cortas.
Ahora, ¿qué sucedió desde 1962? Queremos ver el cambio.
¿Los estudiantes están en lo cierto? ¿Todavía existen dos tipos de países?
¿O estos países en desarrollo han optado por familias más pequeñas y viven aquí?
¿O tienen mayor expectativa de vida y viven hasta aquí?
Veamos. Detuvimos el mundo en este punto. Todas estas estadísticas son de la ONU.
Aquí vamos. ¿Pueden ver allí?
Es China, que se aleja de la mejor salud allí, pero mejora allá.
Todos los países en verde de América Latina tienden a constituir familias más pequeñas.
Los amarillos que ven aquí son los países árabes,
con familias más grandes, pero ellos ---no, vidas más largas, pero no familias más grandes.
Los africanos son los verdes de aquí abajo. Siguen estando aquí.
Esta es India. Indonesia se mueve bastante rápido.
(Risas)
Y en la década del 80 está Bangladesh aún entre los países africanos.
Pero Bangladesh es un milagro de los 80:
los imanes empiezan a promover la planificación familiar.
Se desplazan hacia aquel extremo. Y en los 90, tenemos la terrible epidemia del VIH
que reduce la expectativa de vida en los países africanos.
Y todo el resto se mueve hacia arriba, a la esquina,
donde tenemos muchos años de vida y familias pequeñas y un mundo completamente nuevo.
(Aplausos).
Permítanme hacer una comparación directamente entre Estados Unidos de América y Vietnam.
1964: Estados Unidos tenía familias pequeñas y larga expectativa de vida.
Vietnam tenía familias numerosas y poca expectativa de vida. Y sucedió lo siguiente:
los datos durante la guerra indican que aun con todas las muertes,
hubo una mejora en la expectativa de vida. Hacia finales del año,
se inició la planificación familiar en Vietnam y surgieron las familias más pequeñas.
Y Estados Unidos allá arriba está logrando una vida más larga,
manteniendo el mismo tamaño familiar. Y en los 80,
abandonaron la planificación comunista y adoptaron la economía de mercado,
y se mueve aún más rápido que la vida social. Y hoy, tenemos
en Vietnam la misma expectativa de vida y el mismo tamaño de familias,
aquí en Vietnam, en 2003, que en Estados Unidos, en 1974, hacia el fin de la guerra.
Creo que todos... al no observar los datos...
desestimamos el tremendo cambio producido en Asia, donde
ya se estaba produciendo un cambio social antes de que viéramos el cambio económico.
Vayamos a otro modo en el que podríamos demostrar
la distribución de ingresos en el mundo. Esta es la distribución mundial de ingresos de las personas.
Un dólar, 10 dólares o 100 dólares por día.
Ya no existe la brecha entre los ricos y pobres. Es un mito.
Aquí hay una pequeña protuberancia. Pero hay personas en toda la extensión.
Y si vemos dónde termina el ingreso, este
es 100% el ingreso anual del mundo. Y el 20% más rico,
ellos representan aproximadamente 74%. Y el 20% más pobre,
ellos representan aproximadamente el 2%. Y esto demuestra que el concepto
de países en desarrollo es sumamente dudoso. Concebimos a la ayuda como
"esta gente de aquí brinda ayuda a esta gente de aquí". Pero en el medio,
tenemos a la mayor parte de la población mundial, y ellos tienen ahora 24% del ingreso.
Lo escuchamos en otras formas. Y ¿quiénes son ellos?
¿Cuáles son los países diferentes? Les puedo mostrar África.
Esto es África. El 10% de la población mundial, la mayoría en condiciones de pobreza.
Esto es la OCDE. El país rico. El club privado de la ONU.
Y están aquí, de este lado. Bastante superposición entre África y la OCDE.
Y esto es América Latina. Tiene todo lo que hay en este mundo,
desde los más pobres a los más ricos están en América Latina.
Y además de eso, podemos poner a Europa del Este, Asia del Este,
y Asia del Sur. Y ¿cómo se veía, si volvemos el tiempo atrás,
a aproximadamente 1970? Había más protuberancia.
Y tenemos que la mayoría de los que vivían en pobreza extrema eran asiáticos.
El problema en el mundo era la pobreza en Asia. Ahora si dejamos que el mundo avance,
verán que si bien aumenta la población, hay
cientos de millones en Asia que están saliendo de la pobreza y algunos otros
están entrando a la pobreza y este es el mismo patrón que tenemos hoy.
Y la mejor proyección del Banco Mundial es que esto seguirá sucediendo,
y no tendremos un mundo dividido. Tendremos a la mayor parte de las personas en el medio.
Por supuesto que esta es una escala logarítmica,
pero nuestro concepto de economía es crecimiento con porcentaje. La consideramos
como una posibilidad de incremento del percentil. Si cambio esto, y tomo el
PIB per cápita en vez del ingreso familiar, y transformo estos
datos individuales en datos regionales del producto bruto interno,
y tomo las regiones que están aquí, el tamaño de la burbuja sigue siendo la población.
Y allí tienen a la OCDE, a África Subsahariana allá,
y sacamos los estados árabes de allí,
los que vienen de África y Asia, y los separamos,
y podemos ampliar el eje, y puedo darle una nueva dimensión allí,
al agregar valores sociales allí, como la supervivencia infantil.
Ahora tengo en aquel eje el dinero y la posibilidad de supervivencia infantil.
En algunos países, 99,7% de los niños sobreviven hasta los cinco años;
en otros, sólo el 70%. Y parece que aquí se abre una brecha
entre la OCDE, América Latina, Europa del Este, Asia del Este,
los estados árabes, Asia del Sur y África Subsahariana.
La linealidad entre supervivencia infantil y dinero es muy sólida.
Pero permítanme dividir a los países de África Subsahariana.
Puedo irme aquí y dividir a África Subsahariana en sus países.
Y cuando explota, el tamaño de la burbuja de su país es el tamaño de la población.
Sierra Leona allí. Isla Mauricio está allí arriba. Isla Mauricio fue el primer país
en deshacerse de las barreras comerciales, y pudieron vender su azúcar.
Pudieron vender sus textiles en los mismos términos que en Europa y América del Norte.
Hay una inmensa diferencia entre los países de África. Y Ghana está aquí en el medio.
En Sierra Leona, ayuda humanitaria.
Aquí en Uganda, ayuda para el desarrollo. Aquí, tiempo de invertir, aquí,
podemos ir de vacaciones. La diferencia es enorme
dentro de África y rara vez la hacemos... creemos que todo es igual.
Puedo dividir a Asia del Sur aquí. India es la gran burbuja del medio.
Pero hay una gran diferencia entre Afganistán y Sri Lanka.
Puedo separar a los estados árabes. ¿Cómo son? Tienen el mismo clima, la misma cultura,
la misma religión. Grandes diferencias. Hasta entre países vecinos.
Yemen, guerra civil. Los Emiratos Árabes Unidos, dinero igualitariamente distribuido y bien usado.
No como dice el mito. Y esto incluye a los hijos de trabajadores extranjeros que están en el país.
Los datos generalmente son mejores de lo que piensan. Muchos dicen que son negativos.
Existe un margen de incertidumbre, pero podemos ver la diferencia aquí:
Camboya, Singapur. Las diferencias son mucho más grandes
que los errores de los datos. Europa del Este:
economía soviética por mucho tiempo, pero la abandonaron hace diez años
y de maneras muy, muy diferentes. Y ahí está América Latina.
Hoy no tenemos que irnos a Cuba para encontrar un país saludable dentro de América Latina.
En unos pocos años, Chile tendrá una tasa de mortalidad infantil más baja que la cubana.
Y aquí tenemos a los países de altos ingresos de la OCDE.
Y así tenemos aquí todo el esquema del mundo,
que es más o menos este. Y si lo observamos,
vemos cómo se ve -- el mundo, en 1960, comienza a moverse. 1960.
Este es Mao Tse-tung. Él llevó la salud a China. Y después murió.
Y luego llegó Deng Xiaoping, trajo dinero a China y los reorientó al mundo dominante.
Y hemos visto cómo los países se mueven en diferentes direcciones así,
por lo tanto es difícil encontrar
un país que sirva de ejemplo del patrón del mundo.
Regresemos aquí, a 1960.
Me gustaría comparar Corea del Sur, que es esto, con Brasil,
que es esto. Se me salió el nombre aquí. Y me gustaría comparar Uganda
que está allí. Y puedo avanzar, así.
Y pueden ver cómo Corea del Sur progresa muy rápidamente,
mientras que Brasil es mucho más lento.
Y si volvemos atrás nuevamente, y ponemos marcas, así,
nuevamente se puede ver que la velocidad de desarrollo
es muy, muy diferente, y que los países se mueven más o menos
a la misma velocidad que el dinero y la salud, pero parece que se puede avanzar
mucho más rápido si en primer lugar se tiene salud y no riqueza.
Y para demostrar esto, podemos seguir el camino de los Emiratos Árabes Unidos.
Provienen de aquí, un país minero. Acumularon todo el petróleo,
tienen todo el dinero, pero la salud no se puede comprar en el supermercado.
Hay que invertir en salud. Hay que hacer que los niños accedan a la escolaridad.
Hay que capacitar al personal sanitario. Hay que educar a la población.
Y el Sheikh Sayed lo hizo bastante bien.
Y a pesar de la caída de los precios del petróleo, llevó a este país hasta aquí.
Por lo tanto, tenemos una apariencia mucho más dominante en el mundo,
donde los países tienden a usar su dinero
mejor que en el pasado. Ahora, esto sucede, más o menos,
si observan los datos promedio de los países. Son así.
Ahora, esto es peligroso, usar datos promedios, porque existen muchas
diferencias entre los países. Por lo tanto si me fijo aquí, podemos ver
que hoy Uganda está donde estaba Corea del Sur en 1960. Si divido a Uganda,
hay muchas diferencias dentro de Uganda. Estos son los quintiles de Uganda.
El 20% más rico de los ugandeses están ahí.
Los más pobres allí abajo. Si divido a Sudáfrica es así.
Si bajo y miro lo que sucede en Níger, donde hubo una terrible hambruna,
finalmente es así. El 20% más pobre de Níger está aquí,
y el 20% más rico de África del Sur está allá,
y sin embargo tendemos a debatir sobre las soluciones posibles para África.
En África existe todo lo posible en este mundo. Y no se puede
debatir el acceso universal a las [medicinas] del VIH por este quintil aquí
con la misma estrategia que allí. Las mejoras en el mundo
deben estar contextualizadas y no es relevante hacerlas
a nivel regional. Debemos ser mucho más detallistas.
Encontramos que los estudiantes se entusiasman cuando pueden usar esto.
Y hasta los responsables de las políticas y los sectores corporativos quisieran ver
cómo está cambiando el mundo. Ahora, ¿por qué no sucede esto?
¿No estamos usando los datos que tenemos? Tenemos datos de las Naciones Unidas,
de las agencias nacionales de estadísticas,
de las universidades y de organizaciones no gubernamentales.
Porque los datos se esconden en base de datos.
Y el público está allí, Internet está allí, pero todavía no lo usamos eficientemente.
Toda esta información de cambio en el mundo que vimos
no incluye las estadísticas financiadas por organismos públicos. Hay algunas páginas web
como esta, pero toman parte de su información de las bases de datos,
pero cobran por acceder a ellas, hay que ingresar claves tontas y hay estadísticas aburridas.
(Risas). (Aplausos).
Y esto no funciona. Entonces, ¿qué hace falta? Tenemos las bases de datos.
No se necesitan nuevas bases de datos. Tenemos maravillosas herramientas de diseño,
y se agregan más y más. Por esto creamos
una empresa sin fines de lucro para unir datos con diseño
que llamamos Gapminder, del metro de Londres, donde se advierte:
"cuidado con el agujero". Por eso pensamos que Gapminder era el nombre adecuado.
Y empezamos a diseñar un software para vincular los datos así.
Y fue simple. A algunas personas les llevó años y ahora nosotros podemos producir animaciones.
Se pueden tomar datos fijos y ponerlos allí.
Estamos liberando datos de la ONU, de algunas organizaciones de la ONU.
Algunos países aceptan que sus bases de datos puedan salir del país,
pero lo que realmente necesitamos, sin duda, es una función de búsqueda.
Una función donde podamos copiar los datos en un formato apto para consulta
y darlo a conocer al mundo. Y ¿qué escuchamos?
He estudiado antropología según las principales unidades estadísticas. Todo el mundo dice:
"Es imposible. No se puede hacer así. Nuestra información es tan peculiar
que no puede investigarse como se investigan otras áreas.
No podemos proporcionar los datos a los estudiantes, a los empresarios del mundo gratis".
Pero esto es lo que quisiéramos ver, ¿verdad?
Los datos financiados por organismos públicos están aquí.
Y nos gustaría que crecieran flores en Internet.
Y lo más importante es hacer que estos datos se puedan consultar y que todos puedan usar
las diferentes herramientas de diseño para animarlos.
Y les tengo una buena noticia: el actual
Director de Estadísticas de la ONU dice que no es imposible.
Sólo dice: "No podemos hacerlo".
(Risas).
Es bastante inteligente, ¿verdad?
Podemos ver que sucederán muchas cosas con los datos en los próximos años.
Podremos ver la distribución de ingresos en formas totalmente nuevas.
Esta es la distribución de ingresos de China, 1970.
La distribución de ingresos de Estados Unidos, 1970.
Casi no se superponen en ningún punto. ¿Y qué ha sucedido?
Ha sucedido lo siguiente: que China está creciendo, ya no es tan igualitaria,
y está apareciendo aquí, sobrepasando a Estados Unidos.
Casi como un fantasma, ¿verdad?
(Risas).
Es atemorizante. Pero creo que es importante contar con toda esta información.
Realmente necesitamos verla. Y en vez de cerrar con esto,
me gustaría mostrarles la cantidad de usuarios de Internet por cada 1000.
En este software, accedemos a unas 500 variables de todos los países fácilmente.
Lleva unos minutos cargar esto,
pero en los ejes se puede obtener fácilmente cualquier variable que se quisiera considerar.
Y el objetivo es acceder gratuitamente a las bases de datos,
hacerlas aptas para consulta, y con un segundo clic, transformarlas
en formatos gráficos, donde se puedan comprender instantáneamente.
Ahora, esto no es del agrado de los estadistas porque dicen
que no muestra la realidad. Hay que tener métodos estadísticos, analíticos.
Pero esto es generar hipótesis.
Ahora termino con el mundo. Allí, está llegando Internet.
La cantidad de usuarios de Internet está creciendo así. Este es el PIB per cápita.
Y está la nueva tecnología que vendrá, pero sorprendentemente, qué bien
se adapta a la economía de los países. Por eso será tan importante
el ordenador de 100 dólares. Pero es una tendencia agradable.
Es como si el mundo se estuviera achatando, ¿verdad? Estos países
están aumentando algo más que la economía y será interesante
considerarlo durante un año, y me gustaría que pudieran hacerlo
con todos los datos financiados por organismos públicos. Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)